[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Christina
is in Austin Texas hi Christina how are
you doing good how are you Dave better
than we deserve what's up that's good
thanks for taking our call um so a
little bit of background on us my
husband and I uh we 26 and 28 years old
and um I have um that life settlement
that I've been receiving since I've been
21 um and my husband has disability with
the VA and so outside of our jobs um
we're bringing an income um so alog
together really in a year we probably
beening in about
990,000 um but lately we have been
having a lot of debt um from student
loans to credit cards to car payment um
and I feel like the money that we're
getting to utilize for other things is
just going right to debt um and so we've
been talking around the idea of possibly
selling our home um and paying off our
debt with the equity we've built up over
these last two years um but my husband
he doesn't think it's a good idea he's
scared to do that um and so I don't know
we've just been talking around the idea
and we just wanted to get your input on
that because um this my life settlement
I won't have it forever um and so I
would love to invest that into other
things instead of jet um but I wanted to
hear from you what your thoughts
were well you're not quite ready to
invest we' got to clean up this mess and
selling a home is a big deal and it's
generally kind of a last ditch thing if
we have to to get out of this but I'm
not sure you guys are there yet making
90k how much Consumer Debt do you
have uh so we have about 110 maybe 105
um how much of that is
cars um about
60,000 um that's a lot of
car it is is um and I've actually been
telling my husband for him to get rid of
this truck um I'd rather you get rid of
the truck before the
house yeah and but he doesn't think that
we'll get back enough to pay off the
truck um and so but I I think he should
give it a try to see what how much we'll
get from it but he just doesn't we've
been getting um what's that word we've
been getting uh offers of like 24,000
and we owe about 45 on it still um I
wouldn't look at offers I mean you sell
it private party and you're going to get
way more than offers from
dealerships okay um yeah and so we we
have too many vehicles um and then
school loans is another
40,000 um and then credit cards is
probably about 5 to
7,000 you you make enough to get out of
student loan debt and get out of the
credit card debt if you didn't have the
car payments but your car Cho your car
choices are would have sunk you not your
house okay sell the truck we get rid of
the cars sell the truck okay what are
the payments on those
cars so our so I have uh my car is
$376 um and then his truck is about 740
762 goodness gracious every month so
you'd free up 1,00 bucks just by getting
rid of these cars wouldn't that change
your
life yes it would um could you pay off
some debt with an extra 1100
bucks yeah we could um and right now
we've been throwing a thousand to debt
every month but um it just gets me angry
every month to that we're throwing it to
that you know um and I know yeah you
asked about selling the home George is
right not before we sell both cars and
we work a hard plan with driving a
couple of hoopties working extra
jobs okay what's the nature of the Met
Life settlement what's that from um so
it's from a car accident that I had um
with my family when I was younger I was
about four years old my brother died
from it um and so my parents were
gracious enough to separate some money
for us once we hit
21 um and so at 21 we received 50,000
which I paid another portion of student
loans at the time because I had gone to
a private
institution um and so that went to
student debt but then I still had the
40,000 pending
um when does what I'm sorry when does
the 40
come uh the 40 like the school loans
that's what I right now $40,000 worth of
student loans pending I'm sorry the is
the rest of the money coming from
MetLife a monthly money or a lump sum uh
yes yes uh no monthly money we're get
I'm getting 2,429 for it every month
um uh when I turned 35 so I have about H
nine years to go okay all right yeah you
guys need to get I I the the truck is
glaringly absurd in your in your numbers
it's the thing that sticks out and
scream
stupid okay and yeah it's got to go it's
out of control and U probably your car
too but at least the truck because
you're making 90k driving a $60,000
truck that does not make
sense um nice truck
though uh yeah he's not gonna like to
hear that Dave but he's got yeah well
he's gonna guess what he's not homeless
he's just truckless it's a better choice
the fact that he'd rather sell his house
before his truck tells me that truck is
an ego
play yes okay all right well yeah good
luck with that I hope you talk him into
it cuz that's what you guys need to
do the best thing that you can do you've
got to clear this up and
so goodness gracious yeah I remember
yeah if your truck payment's bigger than
your house payment you might be a
redneck yeah it could be it's possible